comme un air de déjà vu dans les grandes
surfaces les clients sont venus en
nombre dès 10 heures ce matin les
allegrouillez de chariots les rayons se
vident et l attente aux caisses
s'allonger alors que les risques de
pénurie alimentaire sont minimes
ils font partie des sociétés dans
l'obligation de fermer leurs portes les
salons de coiffure ont fait le plein de
clients ce matin la dernière chance de
renouveler sa chevelure avant le
confinement
j'avais réservé déjà parce que c'était
nécessaire ça faisait trois mois que
j'étais parler mais bon
j'ai bien fait dans l'autre parce que je
crois qu'après ces boues que je fais
partie des clients privilégiés oui parce
que j'ai pris mon rendez vous juste à
temps face à cette sur demande la
gérante de cette entreprise s'est
organisé le salon fermera à 21h au lieu
de 19h 4 coiffeuse sont mobilisés elles
attendent près de 20 clients chacune
pour la journée c'est un 24 décembre
aujourd'hui inattendu on n'était pas
préparé à ça on a déployé tout ce qui
était possible de faire pour que la
journée fonctionne bien
celle qui était en vacances sont revenus
celles qui étaient en repos sont venus
aussi porter main forte
même situation dans les restaurants dans
cet établissement dans l'hyper centre de
montigny le bretonneux c'est le dernier
service de midi classique avant
plusieurs semaines de fermeture
une déception pour les habitués fermer
mes petits restaurants préférés là où on
mange très bien on est très bien
accueilli c'est scandaleux
ça va nous manquer je trouve cette
décision ridicule mais bon on s'y tient
contraint et forcé ce midi nous sommes
complets on a une grosse commande
l'ajustement de la vente à emporter
ce soir on a également des réservations
et dès demain donc dès demain nous
ouvrons l'établissement uniquement pour
la vente remporté la dépression une
adaptation incontournable pour ce
restaurant ouvert en février 2020